PROFESSOR: So let's try
to do return to seeing,
OK, we solved equation.
We seem to be OK.
What did we really approximate?
We didn't approximate
saying h bar goes to 0.
We did a more serious
physical approximation.
And let's try to see
what we really did.
So I think the whole clue is
in this top equation there.
You have the first term
and the second term.
And our claim is
that the second term
is smaller than the first
term with h bar there.
So for example-- now of
course, in this solution,
the first term is identically
0 and the second term,
the coefficient of h
bar, is identically 0.
But we can look at one of those,
for example, and say that--
so the validity of
the approximation.
Validity of the approximation.
It's pretty useful to do this.
So we say, for example
there, that term, h bar
s0 double prime that
enters into the order h bar
part of the equation,
the absolute value of it
must be much smaller than
a typical term s0 prime,
for example, s0 prime
squared, in the first term.
So each term-- so
basically, I'm saying
each term in the first
bracket must be much larger
than each term in
the second bracket.
And you could have picked
any ones because they're
all equal, after all.
So let's see if
that is the case.
So recall that s0 prime
from there is really
p of x plus minus p of x.
So what do we have here? h bar
and s0 double prime is dp vx.
Must be much smaller
than p of x squared.
Now it's a matter of playing
with these things a little bit
until you find some way that
the equality tells you story.
And the way I'll
do it is by saying
that this is h bar 1
over p squared of x
dp vx is much smaller than 1.
And here I'll write
this as h bar d--
no h bar.
ddx of h bar over p.
Look what I did.
ddx of 1 over p is 1 over
p squared dp vx and the h
bar I put it there.
Here we go.
What does this say?
This is the local De
Broglie wave length.
This is saying that
ddx of the local
the De Broglie wave length
must be much smaller than 1.
A nice result, your local
De Broglie wavelength
must have a small derivative.
So this is the
physics translation
of the semi-classical
approximation. h bar going to 0
is a mathematical device,
but this is physical.
This is telling you
what should happen.
Most of us look at that
and see an easier way
to understand that equation.
v lambda vx.
It has the right units.
Lambda has units of length.
x has units of length.
So that derivative
must have no units.
And if it's supposed
to be small,
it should be small
compared to 1.
So this is the
conventional inequality.
Most of us would prefer,
maybe, to write it
like this-- lambda d lambda dx
is much smaller than lambda.
And I think this is a
little clearer because this
is how much the De Broglie
wave length changes
over a distance equal to
the De Broglie wavelength.
So you have a De Broglie wave
length and the next De Broglie
wave length.
How much did it change?
That must be small compared
to the De Broglie wavelength.
So the change of
the De Broglie wave
length after you move one
De Broglie wave length
must be smaller than the
De Broglie wave length.
I don't know if you like it.
Otherwise, you
can take this one.
I'll do another one, another
version of the inequalities.
And you can play with
those inequalities.
It kind of takes a while
until you convince yourself
that you're not
missing anything.
Think of p squared equal
to m e minus v of x.
Take a derivative, vvx.
So I'll have p, p prime.
This is 2 pp prime.
But with this 2, I'm
going to cancel it.
At some point, of course, we're
taking all kinds of factors
of 2 and ignoring them.
Remember that true De
Broglie wave length is h over
p not h bar over p.
Factors-- by the time you go
to this inequality, two pis
are gone.
m.
We're differentiating
with respect
to x and taking absolute value.
So we'll write it like this.
Or vvvx vx equals
1 over m pp prime.
That is so far exact.
Let me multiply by a lambda.
So I'll have a lambda.
And a lambda, vv dx,
is equal to lambda.
OK.
Lambda is h bar over p.
So I can cancel one of these p's
and get h bar over m p prime.
OK.
H bar over m p prime.
Now, look at this equation.
I'm sorry.
We'll play with this a little--
like, trial and error.
You're trying to move
around your inequality.
So here we have
something-- h bar
dp dx is much less than that.
So this term is because
of this inequality
is much smaller than
p squared over m.
And now we have something nice.
I'll write it here.
Lambda of x dv dx is much
smaller than p squared over 2m.
That's another nice one.
I think this one is the--
and this says that the potential
must be slowly varying for this
to be true because the change
in the potential over at the De
Broglie wavelength--
dv dx times lambda of x
is an estimate for the change
of the potential over the De
Broglie wavelength-- is much
smaller than the kinetic energy
of the particle.
So that's, again, another
thing that makes sense.
It's kind of nice.
So this is the wave at
the end of the day, this h
bar going to zero
approximation has
become a physical statement.
It is a statement of
quantities varying
slowly because after all, that's
what motivated the expansion
from the beginning.
So let's see if we ever
get in trouble with this.
So we're trying to solve
physical problems of particles
and potentials.
And most of the times
we're interested in bound
states or energy eigenstates,
at least the simple energy
eigenstates are bound states.
So here is a situation.
We have a sketch of a situation.
We have a v of x--
this is x.
This is a.
v of x-- and some energy, e.
And let's assume we're
looking close enough
to the point x equals a so that
the v of x, however it curves,
at that point is
roughly straight.
That's a reasonable thing to do.
So we'll model v of x minus e--
v of x minus e-- as being
linear near x equals a.
So this is g times
x minus a, where
g is some positive
constant, which
is the slope at this point.
So look at x less than a.
At this point, you are
in the loud region.
You're in the region to
the left of the point a
where your energy is
bigger than the potential.
And that's perfectly allowed.
So here, e minus v of x,
which is the negative of that,
would be g a minus x.
And p is square root of 2 m e
minus v of x, so g a minus x.
That's p of x.
So that's your position
dependent momentum.
It's going to go
to 0 at that point.
And lambda, which
is h bar over p,
is h bar over square
root of 2 mg 1
over square root of a minus x.
So take the derivative--
d lambda d x--
take the absolute value of it.
That's h bar over square root of
2 mg times 1/2 1 over a minus x
to the three halves.
We're differentiating
with respect to x.
And now you see the trouble,
if you had not seen it
before, the validity of the
semi-classical approximation
is taken and requires d lambda
dx to be much smaller than 1.
And as you approach x equals
to a, this grows without bound.
It just becomes
bigger and bigger.
You can choose g to be large and
you can choose m to be large.
But still, you get closer and
closer, you eventually fail.
This thing goes to
infinity as x goes to a
and grows without limit.
And the semi-classical
approximation crashes.
You know, I would imagine
that many people got this far
with this in my classical
approximation of writing
this and that.
But this is a
tremendous obstacle.
Why is it an obstacle?
Why can't we just
forget about that region
because most of the times you
dealing with bound states.
So you will have a very
slowly varying potential here.
But if you want to
find bound states,
you need the fact that there
is a forbidden region where
the wave function
destroys itself.
So whatever you can solve
for the wave function
is slowly varying here.
It's not enough because you
need to know how it decays.
And therefore, you need
to face this corners
where the semi-classical
approximation fails.
Our problem here is that we know
how to write a solution here.
We probably know how to
write the solution here.
Those are these ones.
But we have no idea
how to write them here.
So we cannot connect
the two solutions.
It's a serious difficulty.
So people work hard on that.
And I think that
is the breakthrough
of the construction of
this WKBP [INAUDIBLE]..
What they did is they
solved the equation
exactly in this region,
assuming a linear potential.
They solved it exactly.
And then those functions, the
[INAUDIBLE] functions, show up.
And you know how the
[INAUDIBLE] functions behave.
So they solve it here.
They related it to the solution
to the right, related it
to the solution on the left.
And in that way,
even though we don't
have to write the
solution in this region,
we know how a
solution on the middle
connects to a
solution on the right.
This is the subject of the
connection formulas in WKB.
We will discuss that
next time, or we'll
go through some of that analysis
because it's interesting
and fairly non-trivial.
But I will mention one of the
connection formulas and use it.
That's the rest of what
we're going to do today.